History Channel's hit drama Vikings
features many characters who wear
tattoos to play up their ancient tribal
nature of course the actual history
can't say for sure if that was a
cultural truth historical accuracy is
always slippery for television dramas
and on top of that the records
pertaining to the Viking people as they
live - all from third parties since they
kept no written records of their own
for instance rule though sir Gerson
Ragnar lothbrok brother is loosely based
on a man that lived at the end of the
ninth century that did indeed abandon
his Nordic roots to become the first
Duke of Normandy Rollo just exactly this
on Vikings although the real-life man
almost certainly wasn't at the actual
sacking of Paris and was definitely not
related to Ragnar in fact Ragnar can't
be proven to ever have existed at all
outside the written epics in which he's
featured whether or not the Viking
people are tatted up like the characters
on the History Channel show some of the
ink shown on the series represents
important aspects of the Viking
mythology in particular Rollo has
several elaborate tattoo designs
accompanying all the characteristic
weaving not structures across his torso
are a paragraph wolves on his arm which
represent a deeper cut of Viking
folklore the most the two wars Rollo has
tattooed a brothers borne of the great
wolf Fenrir in Norse mythology the twin
wolves are named Haiti and skull names
are loosely translates to hate and
mockery in English the two wars were in
most versions of the tale the sons of
Fenrir and a werewolf mother being a
creature of darkness and a son of Loki
Fenrir is eventually imprisoned in
magical chains by Odin and the rest of
the divine Pantheon until the Norse
interpretation of the Apocalypse
Ragnarok his wolf sons are enraged by
the axe and after failing to free him
begin chasing the astrological avatars
of the Sun and Moon the siblings sol and
money as it many creationist myths the
brother-sister duo pour the celestial
bodies around the world in perpetuity
Fenrir is meant to consume Odin when
chaos B asserts itself and Ragnarok
arrives so his sons haiti and skull are
designed to eventually catch and eat
saleh money to plunge the universe back
into the darkness from whence it emerged
in a 2014 video shot for history's
youtube channel vikings makeup
department head Tom McClure knee and
Rollo actor clive standin spoke about
the characters
well mcclenney initially joked that he
had no idea what all those tabs meant
and that the makeup team too slapped a
bunch on his skin for no reason
standin interjected with a laugh to
explain that Rollo means famous wolf
which factors into the wolf tattoos he
has mcclure knee piggybacked off that
commenter detail we have two wolves in
Norse mythology chasing the moon and the
Sun one eating the Sun and one devouring
the moon it was only a matter of seconds
before the makeup department head was
cracking jokes again he was so adamant
that he wanted to get his shirt up over
time only that I have to shave his chest
cuz he's half bear it's fitting for
Rollo in particular to bear tattoos for
such history he is the one who initially
suggests a raise that makes him and his
brother famous which is a particularly
dark omen for history right off the cuff
along with that effective historical
characterization the tattoos of Haiti
and skull that Rolly rocks is fitting
for the place he has a relationship to
his family and the rest of his clan he's
separated from them by bitterness that
eventually blooms into hatred and acts
out against them by joining their
enemies this all goes to show that even
the smallest artistic touches can be
used by a costume or art designer to
give flavor and death that only the most
devoted audience would seek to learn
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]